[Music]
and big news guys we have a special
guest on the phone
Maxine by Sheila Grove he is calling in
from Paris welcome to the show Maxine
yeah hello Dan hello everyone hello
Peter
hey there Elmo hey how are you feeling
to myself as this moment you must be
well that you must be on pins and
needles worried about what's gonna
happen no I mean I think for a ring of
course I mean I would be lying inside
inside didn't but right after centuries
I thought my chances of qualifying were
like 15 to 20 percent basically right
now it's probably over 50 so like all
bonus of course and it's also very hard
for me to be working against reach it
but that's sad low of support and yeah
all you know you know whether I qualify
or don't qualify it's not the end of the
world anyway because of just yeah I'm
focusing on Jerusalem right now you
watch me Maxine when Vishnu Flags sorry
were you watching that critical game
where the chief lash oh yeah I think
that game with an airship versus it's
always out breaking in a way I was being
confronted to a lot of you know moments
were filled with pressure and the
nitesite I'm thinking I haven't been
doing that battling those moments
because it just that I've been converted
to much more fun than others it seems
like magnetical fun winning the
tournament
prions before the end but whenever you
think the pressure is not playing as
good
I didn't think we she would be feeling
the pressures of because he had so much
experience
we've been playing World Championship
matches but
chess is a 10th game and in represented
it just comes out to show your
predictions in this game Maxine how do
you feel about the position I'm not
watching this game I'm coding you so
so I don't know there's a tremendous
sharp Jokinen on the board with black
already having played h 5 h 4g 4 HD for
Bishop g4 it'd be good for black but yes
it's first 94 is currently the the by
far the most critical move in the
position but she decides to wait for a
bit and go and go King G one instead
sorry King H one perhaps with the
intention of if you play like sorry they
take you for your beating
I was actually going to make the exactly
opposite point because with the ABA
after 94 Bishop f3 Bishop of three eg
there is a five and the rook on a8 is
hanging so I was a I was actually I was
pretty sure that was his point and never
I thought this was why he took on a 6b
ah ba ba - 1 I don't quite understand
though I don't really know why these two
moves are connected anyway like again
whatever happens is not is not critical
and it's a to my development as a chess
player will be much more critical but
has it occurred to you that in terms of
preparing for Jerusalem it's better for
you to not play London well I mean I'm
gonna be like right away and the thing
is I mean in the week before Jerusalem
and the choice is between whether I'll
be wasting because you know I I think I
might like or whether it be playing
chess and you know may be better for me
in the sense to train in London
because I was not gonna single em and
then the pressure might not build up I
don't know you know it's a very very
unorthodox situation I mean even if it's
getting mono familiar from surprising
here the game has been agreed to a drama
team which means that the tension just
mounts and probably it'll come down to
the very last round but one thing we can
say for sure is that whoever ends up in
London is a very deserving contender for
the grand chest or title thanks for
joining us on the phone Maxine thanks
for calling
yeah thank you
[Music]